こんにちはドクターはじめだ皆さんは
スライムというものをご存知だろうか
ドクター始めが最初に作ったのはいつだっ
ただろうか結構昔にスライムを作ってそれ
からなんとかスライムの実験や研究をして
きたわけだがスライムの魅力それは何か
もちろんこのビヨーンて伸びる感じだっ
たり手触りとかもそうなんですけども人は
なぜスライムに魅了されるのかそれは
色なんです皆さん色スライムって言われる
とドクター始め的には黄緑色を
思い浮かべるんだがスライムって本当に色
が無限にあるわけだそれなぜかと言うと
スライム作る時に自分で色をつけれるん
ですよチャミー神なんですねこれという
わけで今回ドクターはじめ何をしたかと
言いますとふんなんとこちら19色の
絵の具セットですちょっと見てみましょう
かおーこれかなんとこちらの絵の具
プロフェッショナルウォーターカラーお
値段なんと約7万円ですそれはこんだけ色
あったら名前にするわな開けてみましょう
オープン
ザップラジオポック動物動物
うわーすごいですよ皆さんこれ今回こちら
に109色の絵の具準備しましたいやでも
ちょっと待てよこれほぼ一緒だぞ
黄色だけでアンミカさんこれ何色あるん
ですかこれ
これで109色なんですけどもちょっと
109キリが悪いのでちょっと気に食わ
ない色から排除します黄色いのでこれは
以上泥っぽいからこれも排除これいらん
これもいらないいらないこれで給食分除い
たので100食になりましたというわけで
今日はスライム100食分作ってみたいと
思います
これはねなかなかできることじゃないと
思いますよそしてドクターはじめ今から
スライム100食分作って並べたら多分
綺麗すぎると思うのでそれを眺めて気持ち
よくなりそしてその後その100色の
スライムをまとめたら何色になるのか
ちょっと実験していきたいと思います
[音楽]
作っていきます
というわけで早速作っていこうと思います
材料ホウ酸2kg洗濯のり8Lコップ
100個あとは水とお湯があれば作れます
1個目は丁寧に作っていきましょうかまず
密度洗濯のりを1対1で入れて混ぜますお
水で同じ量の洗濯のりで水と洗濯のり
入れるの混ぜますこのタイミングで好きな
色入れますまずはスライムカラーの
グリーンドクターはじめといえば黄緑
みたいなとこありますからね入れていき
ますよはいこれ結構多分ね入れた方が色の
発色良くなるからいいねめっちゃスライム
やんで次にもう1つ容器を準備してお湯
ちょっと準備しますこの中にポーザーを
ちょびっと入れますとまあなんか適当に
気持ち入れといてくださいお湯だとホウ砂
がすぐ溶けるともう一瞬で溶けましたで
ホウ砂の入ったこのお湯をこっちに入れる
と
これを混ぜるとなんと
はいスライムの完成です
あやばいわこれ生きのできたないやいや
めっちゃ綺麗これ
ザスライムみたいな色になったなてかずみ
スライム作るのうますぎても完璧なんだ
けどとろみとかスライム作るポイントの
コツとして交差を入れるお湯なるべく
あったかい熱い方がいいです重さが粉の
まま混ぜちゃうとダマになっちゃうので
まんべんなく綺麗なトロトロスライム作り
たい時はなるべくホースを溶かして入れて
くださいやばい最高じゃんこんなの
おもしれえ
[音楽]
これを100回やりますというわけで
スライムグリーン完成したんですけども
ここから一気に99個作っていこうと思い
ますまずはカップを100個置いていき
ますいきます
[音楽]
このカップ99個に洗濯なると水を1対1
で入れてきます
[音楽]
はいこれで水と洗濯のり1対1で100
カップ入れ終わりました
というわけでここからスライムに色をつけ
ていきますいやすごいよまずいろんな色
ありますからほんとこれ全部カラフルに
なるぞ今からすごいぞー
[音楽]
あれちょっと待ってくださいちょっと待っ
てこれ思ったんですけど色の名前長くない
これとかマジやばいんだけど何これ
カドミウムスカーレットで行くレートで
カドミニアムエスカレーターで
カディミーノみたいな赤いやつありますね
高級な絵の具だからかな全部名前が長い
やばいマジでこれやばい1個ずつ紹介して
いこうと思います
ドリンバ中でテラオブソングラン
ナチュラル
[音楽]
来たね1個目これ
ちゃんさむ全然
チャンスコア
いい色ですね
[音楽]
ベネチアン
レッドルージュベニンが
ライトレッド空中クライアン
バリンと新年になったタリメタガタ
一緒やん一緒やんこれもマグネシウム
ブラウザ
こんな色ばっかりクインカニンドン
ゴールドメカ
ビタグリーンブルーシェードでNEXT
WINNER
めっちゃ綺麗スライムっぽいこれこういう
の待ってたカドミウムフリーオレンジ
素敵なイエローっぽいなこれチャイニーズ
ホワイト白いスライムはできそうな気が
するまたガスからロキシーニューム
綺麗ではないなエメラルドブルーあー
爽やかな色ジャスティングレーあーマジで
これは黒いやつできるな
歯磨きミントあーでも割と綺麗そうだなお
茶っ葉グリーン
[音楽]
こうレモンイエロー
素敵な色ねバナナイエロー
100%グミレモンイエロー
キャロットレッド
めっちゃきれいトマトニームレッドあー
めっちゃ綺麗な赤なのこれ曇り色の空
うわぁポカリスエット
商品化されそう
健康グリーン落ち着いた緑イオン
ウォーター
工事現場の注意の色
チェリーレッドシンプルな黄色
口紅レッド
めっちゃ綺麗
豚っぽいピンク
薄めのやつねモテそうな青なかなか素敵な
発色してますね
めっちゃ綺麗セクシーピンクこれも
なかなかビビットな色してますね
抹茶グリーン
抹茶っぽいです
エナジードリンク
めっちゃ色じゃんこれ
いいね
夏バイオレットビタミンイエロー
ビタミンイエロー2ビタミンイエロー3
ビタミンa6567
グラシアスブルー
ロイヤリティー
うんこ発色が良くて綺麗ブラウニー
チョコレートチョコレートっぽいな
ラベンダーパープル
ダークパープル大
納言小豆
納言小豆2大納言3スーパー紫色スーパー
ピンクスーパー
ムラサキハイドロブルー多いお茶サファリ
グリーンハッピーオレンジ
オレンジレンジレンジオレンジレンジ
レンジレンジバニシングレッドスモーキー
グリーンスケベイエローココナッツ
オレンジカロリーメイトスパニッシュ
イエローセクシャル大空翼イエロー
ジャパニーズレッドピンクウーロン
ソーシャルメディアクショングリーン
ハイパーイエローコラボニックグリーン質
の良いお肉ソフトレッドスクランブルピン
バーモントイエロー
グレネードトムソンブルーブラックブラックブルー
よしこれで全てのスライムに色がつきまし
た100色ですはい
あとは簡単ですお湯を準備して
黄砂を溶かし入れます100個一気に作っ
たことないからさわかんないんだよなこん
だけ水あるから結構入れちゃっていいと
思います
でしょ行きます
ほらこれでスライムになれば
なってるなってるはいスライム完成しまし
たというわけでホウ砂を溶かしたお湯を
これ全部に冷凍なんと
たい
というわけでスライム100食完成しまし
た
すごいこれどこだって色これ
青とかでも全然色が違うしこれすごいで
これ100色以上あんねんかこれ200色
あんねんこれちょっとスケルトンなブルー
とかもなかなかいいですねこれとかザ
スライムみたいな色しててめっちゃ綺麗で
最高じゃんスライム
キングちょっとさすがにドクターはじめ
テンション上がるわこんだけカラフルな
スライムあるとちょっと
圧巻ですねというわけで早速これを全部お
風呂場に持ってって遊んでいきたいとあ
違った実験していきたいと思います
どうもというわけでお風呂場に来ました
さすがにこの量のスライムで遊ぶ時は
なかなかいつもの実験ラボではできません
こちらのちょっとエッチなジャグジーのお
風呂場を使ってスライムで遊んでいきたい
と思いますあ実験していきたいと思います
マジでどうしようでも一番しライルっぽい
色がいいから
最初作ったやつちょっと
遊んできますよ
というわけでめっちゃ綺麗やば1食で
こんなに綺麗だからすごいよもうこれ
はい皆さんこれただ遊んでるだけではなく
最終的な目標を全部混ぜたら何色になるの
か見ていきたいと思います
まずは緑できましたとでちょっと多分黒色
とか入れると絶対黒くなるのであんまり
濃い色は入れずにカラフルなやつだけ
混ぜると何色になるのか見ていきたいと
思います最後は全部混ぜるけどじゃあ次は
この爽やかなオレンジスライム出してっ
ちゃうぜー
めっちゃ綺麗的な色今夜から開けていき
ますオレンジ色も入れてみますじゃあ
スライムカラースライムといえばこの色の
イメージあるかなビビットピンク
めっちゃ黄色いのなんか結構俺の中で好き
な色をだいぶ出たんで1回これ全部混ぜて
みようと思いますいくぜ
蛇口壊れないから果たして何色になるのか
めっちゃ綺麗じゃない今のところ最終的に
は全部混ぜるんだけど
気持ち悪い気持ち悪いやばいやばいやばい
やばい
混ぜたらこんな色になりましたこんな感じ
になっちゃいました
ただ皆さんまだ慌てる時間じゃありません
俺にはなんせあと95尺ありますから
色んな色が出たらもっと綺麗になること
間違いなし開けていきましょうよっしゃー
[音楽]
とりあえず
綺麗なスライムだけ全部打ち込み終わり
ましたはいというわけで
環境破壊しそうな色のスライム以外の
カラフルなスライム全て入れ終わりました
ちょっと
芸術に感じない色が完全に混ざり合って
ないけどもお互いをなんとなく干渉し合っ
ているそんな素敵な状態ですそのまま
キープしておきたいですこのまま終わらせ
ては実刑にならんどうせだったらこの全て
のスライムを混ぜ合わせると何色になるの
かちょっとやって
いきたい色は全て省いてあるのでマジで
わからないです何色
になるこれ混ぜていきましょう俺の作品が
俺の
破壊と再生をテーマにした作品が今音を
立てて
壊れて行きますさあどうなっちゃうの
でしょうか
頑張って混ぜていこうと思います
すごい
[音楽]
めっちゃ綺麗なこれやばすぎコスモを
感じる
[音楽]
ほらこれがねぇよ
検証結果綺麗な色のスライム混ぜると
うんこになってしまいましたあんなに綺麗
だったのにたどり着いたのがこれを
なんだか
なぁって事か
[音楽]
なんか本当は黒になるかなと思ってたん
ですけど
茶色って結構意外でしたね意外と赤と黄色
が多かったからかわかんないですけど一応
結果は茶色でしたただまだ100色全部
混ぜてないのでここら辺の黒いやつらも1
回全部混ぜてみたいと思います
果たして濃い色も含めて100色混ぜたら
何色になるのでしょうか
[音楽]
はい全部入れ終わりましたこれで全て
100色ですだいぶ黒が入りますね
果たしてこの茶色のスライムは何色になっ
ちゃうんでしょうかどうなると思うままだ
と思いますいや俺はね黒になると思う黒
ってやばいからね
結構まんべんなく混ぜたんですけどもなん
かちょっと
緑かかった
土かなさっきとは全然赤みがかなり消えた
感じがしましたいやうんこや